We're meeting
kitchen.
Um,
and there's the middle
section of the poem,
literally a place of transition between,
uh,
the have the world of health and, and,
and all the evil that we have witnessed.
And then the, the, the realm of glory,
which is going to be paradise. Um, uh,
let me say a few things about purgatory,
both as an idea and, uh, as, as a,
a poetic construction, Dante's
poetic construction, um,
as an idea, uh, the were
Dante understands it.
Precatory is part of a human geography,
as you know, it's, uh, located
in the southern hemisphere.
There are two hemispheres
in medieval geography,
the Northern Hemisphere,
which is that when we inhabit,
and then there is the southern hemisphere,
uh,
the purgatory is an island.
I have tried to explain to you last time
the origin of this place in Nantucket
Mitchell boy, uh, uh,
thinking, uh, it, uh,
it's an island that emerged from the
northern hemisphere at the time of
Lucifer's for, uh, the
earth trembles and retreats.
That's the idea,
uh,
as Lucifer approaches and such does,
it creates the void,
which becomes hades, the
abyss and the island. And the,
the purgatory emerges on the other side,
the southern hemisphere,
the top of the pool. That story there
is the island of, there is the, the,
the peak is the garden of Eden.
They are where God placed
Adam and eve. So that, uh,
from this point of view,
purgatory is part of human geography,
but it's historically in
accessible to human beings.
One hero that already we
already met you listen in,
in federal 26 tries to approach
an island at retrospectively,
we can understand that that was,
uh, the island of purgatory.
This is a place of immortality that
you listeners wanted to reach and uh,
could not that journey of his and the,
the shipwreck and tragically,
uh, in federal 26 is the text
for that kind of concern.
The other trait about a
purgatory moral trade, uh,
since this is now,
uh,
we are going to enter the
realm of reconstruction of
the human and the soul to
make sense. A dentist should
place it immediately after hell.
It is as if only by knowing,
only by experiencing more or less as
metaphoric ways we can through the poetry
of Dante.
The nature of evil and the horror of it.
Can we begin to have an
appreciation of, uh, of the good,
the good toad, which, uh,
now the pilgrim is going to climb.
The other,
the other thing that you should keep
in mind about, uh, uh, about, uh,
progress or in the difficulties that the
poet we'll have, uh, is the following.
Uh,
the perception of moral life and political
life in purgatorial was so satanic,
so narrow, so terrible that Dante's
going to have a lot of quite a,
quite a,
quite a challenge to try to explain the,
the usefulness and,
and the,
and the possibility of reconstructing
a moral world and the political world.
He was, he came very close
to a total rejection of a,
of a historical world
and the political world.
And now he has to find out how that
reconstruction is going to be possible.
The way he will do this is literally
to go back to the natural world.
Do not expect Dante to imagine a place
where there is some kind of redemptive
intervention from the outside. I can tell
us this is the way you do it. No, no.
The natural world, a
world, the natural world,
it must be capable of
producing within itself.
Some at least contain some seeds for a
need to reconstruct for a need for the
good. So this is going to
be part of, uh, uh, his,
uh, his strategy and his difficulties
at further tray to purgatory,
which was really completely
missing in the Fed.
And the Fed we had never
had a sense of time.
Time was the biological clock of the
pilgrim who was the only living creature,
the only truly displaced figure.
And he is the only displaced figure
throughout the poem and purgatory who will
find further. They're all displaced
figure. So it's a more human, uh,
world. Uh, but here now they have
their sense of time. In fact,
the first thing that we, we,
we come to understand is how,
what time is it's time
understood as future oriented,
as a projection in some kind of future.
And at the same time,
this idea of time also turns out to be
in a return to the past so that as the
pilgrim is going ahead, he's literally
discovers that he's going backwards.
To the garden of Eden exactly there where
Adam and eve were placed at the top.
Who Purgatory.
Bye Bye,
bye God at that time in the store
that you have in, in Genesis,
uh, uh, for instance.
But this idea of time,
this will become truly a light motif
throughout full authority idea of what is
the relationship between
the past and the future,
since the only real time is really the
future. And from that point of view are,
which makes you understand that even
the past was the future at some point at
least.
Right?
So the future is the only thing that
Dante is going to be interested in and the
future will come and the possibility of
a future and the way it's related to the
past will become,
are the object of his concerns,
the object of his thinking or openly
as he goes through the various Ah,
ah, Ah, the Veterans Ledger.
So purgatory, poetically,
the poor guitar is divided into two,
two to three parts.
I would say actually the,
the first part is the so called anti
purgatory made of souls were awaiting,
uh, don't, don't really penitence yet,
but waiting to be assigned a
particular place along the ledges.
And then the so called penitents who are
going through the process of cleansing,
beginning with pride and ending
up with ending with luxury at, uh,
just before the pilgrim gets
into the garden of Eden.
The ordering of sins is the exact
reversal of the ordering of,
since you had an in fair no,
here you begin with a spiritual,
sane or intellectual saying the question
of pride and end up with the most
physical and material of the more luxury,
which as you'll recall,
is the, the inverted image of what
happened in, in, uh, in, in fan.
All right. With the Lucifer and the scene
of Lucifer being really seen of, uh,
of pride at the end of Ken to 30 for the,
well, having said this, maybe other things
will come to mind as I go on. Uh, uh,
uh, today. And let me begin
with, uh, uh, with, uh,
some other couple of details is
just getting to plunge into the,
the can to one where, where
is the pilgrim? Now, the poem,
the journey began on a good Thursday,
as it's called,
right? The Dante spends the
first night, but the journey,
the real journey begins on Good
Friday in a clear imitation of a,
uh,
Christ's,
a harrowing of Hell and emergence
into the light on a Easter Sunday.
That's where we are now.
Easter Sunday morning,
if the federal begins at dusk,
and therefore, uh, the, the,
with the idea of the approaching night
and night that stands for the and no
ability of whatever
he's going to confront.
The dentists fascinated with the
idea of the night throughout, uh,
in fan reimagine.
Remember a Ulysses who travels following
the sun and then the, and, and,
and ends up really gazing at tonight,
the unknowability of his destiny.
They had no ability of the
place even where he is.
Now we'll begin with dawn and therefore
10 to one of purgatory becomes that
which in province our literature,
it's called an Obod. Oh,
from the word [inaudible] in
Italian a U, B a, d, e the,
the song, the dawn song, a song
that in many ways reverses,
uh, the grand tradition of, uh,
the erotic lyrics of a,
of a province are, uh,
poetry,
uh,
where the dawn becomes the unhappy
time for the parking of lovers.
And here now it's regained as
the great time when finally, uh,
um,
the pilgrim can go on and the port and
go and mapping literally now mapping the
journey,
sailing through or sending is the metaphor
that he asks a that he adopts or can
be in deployment. The second part of the
point purgatorio begins first of all,
with an image of water
and, and, and therefore it,
it carries further this motif of
the cleansing and purification.
But really with a better metaphor from
our point of view to course of a better
waters,
there'll bock who my width now
lifts her sales leaving behind her.
So courtesy and that will sing of that
second kingdom where the human spirit is
purged,
it becomes fit to ascend to heaven.
But here,
let poetry rise again from the dead
or holy musers since I am yours.
And he'll let Kalia pay rise
up for awhile. And the company,
my song without strain,
which smote the ears of the wretched
pies so that they despaired of,
pardon, it's an extraordinary
problem, uh, to,
to purgatorial with for a
number of reasons. First of all,
[inaudible] picks up the
metaphor of the, the, the,
the epic oppose the epic
metaphor of, uh, of,
uh, the, the, the journey, uh,
with which the poem began in the middle
of the journey of our life as you recall.
But now this, uh, uh, this, this,
this idea of the process is
indicated with a all failing.
Therefore, literally recalling the, the,
the sea voyage of Ulysses. What's,
that's one an oblique metaphor,
but I want to draw your attention
to the use of this adjective,
a comparative adjective. That's where
we call it in grammar, as you recall,
the better waters.
Uh,
it's Dante's emphasis at
exactly on the process.
And then the con, the comparatively
good. This is not the best of waters.
It's not the worst of worst. This is
the better waters. We are really in the,
on the way to, uh, to better things. It's,
it's a world of be green,
uh,
that Dante introduces visit
that have really believes in a,
in a sort of hierarchy, in
the hierarchy of, uh, of,
of values, of states,
of, uh, of powers, of a,
of beauty, of intellect, the world be a,
it's an a dualistic world between
what's bad and what's good.
They said a lot of mediations,
mediating steps along the way,
and now he already
introduced this, this, this,
this whole question with an ocean of
the better waters, the little backroom,
my witness.
This is not only a journey.
The interesting thing is
this is a journey of poetry.
It is as if Dan Pennell wants to highlight
a motif which is going to be very
crucial throughout the poem and in our
reading of this poem that they really,
at this point,
I have been addressing this issue.
So some of your questions
that there really is no sharp,
no drastic discontinuity between the,
the journey of the pilgrim at
the journey of the port, right.
That the journey of the
poet is an extension.
It in itself is a journey in itself,
is a journey of knowledge and a
journey of discovery. And Dante makes,
uh, a large claims for poetry.
Poetry is a way of knowing.
It's just not a and ornamentation
recommed memorization of the past.
Now here he talks about the journey
has been the journey of poet,
the little bark of my weight.
It's a conventional way of thinking about
the bark of poetry with which he is.
So they say, there seems to be a way of
saying this is now more at this stage,
at least it was to us to think about
the journey of poetry and not just the
journey that he himself will
use. Uh, we'll, we'll, we'll,
we'll undertake the journey of the
pilgrim, the hard, difficult to journey,
uh, filled with fear, uh, that, uh,
that he was experiencing
in, in, in, in federal.
And I also want to draw your attention
to another little detail of the text.
This is this the first time now
that Dante, we use the future tense.
I will thing we're in the world to open
to futility and if it's open to future,
the only way of thinking about futurity
is made possible by a belief in the new.
You have to not really think,
yes you can think of the future,
but if the future is exactly
as as as it is today,
then you really have no future,
then you really think that all is
released into the domain of sameness.
You know, if my day today is
exactly what more the the,
the world that I experienced yesterday,
there's no new,
no idea of the new and that instead
here now users the future and clearly
implying that there is an alternative,
a difference,
a possibility of doing things in
ways that have not been done before.
This is going to be a new departure
and new departure for thoughts and new
departure for the imagination and now he
says it has to be also a new departure
for poetry itself.
I emphasize this idea of the future,
I will sing the first time that he will.
He wasn't saying this in fan.
Of course he couldn't even say that
in the Vita Nuova you remember that I
pointed when we were reading the little
autobiographical great text called the
Vita Nuova,
the beginning of the term.
I indicated to you that there is
never the future tense used in that,
in that,
uh,
in that text it was all a book of mammary
with the difficulties and the dangers
of mammary.
Dangerous with memory being that memory
changes can draw us into a world of
fantastic. That's one of the,
it's not a rejection of memory,
only a way of highlighting.
It's possible dangerous,
right in the belief that they should
live with some idea of danger.
Maybe we are not really thinking are
hard enough. So here now it's the, the,
the only time that the future was using
the Vita Nuova was either in the idea of
death,
when Dante has a prophetic dream and
he hears a voice that he perceives as a
kind of so,
so,
so truth leading is that voice that
he thinks of it as a kind of, uh,
of profits is a Soto of Oracle
speaking to him. You too will die.
Beatrice has just died.
And then the death of Beatrice brings
to his mind the fear and threat of
mortality to him.
You too will die.
That's the way the future's going
to be understood. But then the poem,
the whole Vita Nuova ends
with a statement of hope.
I hope to work and write things
whereby I can say I can dry.
I can say things about,
uh, uh, about Beatrice.
I had never been said about any woman.
And so that becomes the two possibilities.
So that's usually the only, literally
once grammatically, the future tense.
And the other one with, through this,
uh, petty faster construction too.
So bleak construction. But the
hope, the verb, we use that to, uh,
in with the idea of the future
indicator there and then, uh,
but he'll let poetry
rise again from the dead
and the prayer to the musers very much
in the style of the epic tradition and
especially of the music two one,
the Muse of the epic poetry Kaleo pay.
But then this,
the focus on Calliope we really tells
you something about the kind of, uh,
uh,
I think retrospectively Reid explains,
but let here they'd poetry
rise again from the dead.
Uh,
the poem presents itself as clear.
It was the mother of
whom anybody remember?
You remember your mythology,
okay. No, you don't now, but it's,
it's the mother of all fears so that
they let their poetry rise again.
Uh, let that poetry rise
again from the dead. It's,
Dante presents himself as it were, a
Norfolk poet. He was Nora Norfolk poets,
but it's for the airport
in the traditional Morpheus
who wants to conquer death.
That's clearly enough for him.
That's,
that's what the old fuse descent
into the underworld really is.
The way of conquering death,
the belief that poetry can do the trick.
That's true poetry. We immortalize
ourselves, we conquered death.
He's going very soon to talk to him to
understand that that's not the way he is
going to do that. And then
something, a second paragraph,
I want to read it a little bit because
it really gives us a different sense of
the tonality of Purgatorio because
there's not only you have now morning and
time,
you also have for the first time light,
not this hotel have a
spectacular shades of light.
The blue, the reds, uh, uh,
the green with which he experiences and
dramatizes paradise according to the
lights emanating from the various planets,
red of Mars,
the white of Jupiter, the blue of
Saturn. And so there is a kind of public,
chromic, a pallette that is
going to be deployed here.
It's now a more human and natural world,
the natural world. And listen to this.
And then this enables me to say
something else about the traits of,
or the sweet hue of the Oriental Sapphire,
which was gathering this region,
face of the heavens from the
cleared zenith to the first circle.
Gladden my eyes again.
As soon as I passed out of the day there
we should affected my eyes and breast.
They're fair planet that prompts
to our Venus the morning,
the morning star that loved me,
the older east laughs veiling the
fissures, which were in her trains.
I turned to the right.
You remember that? I,
I sort of tried to explain to you that
with one exception that I can't explain,
nobody can explain.
And on very few people have noticed,
uh, the, the, uh, Dante now
is turning to the right,
which is to say that even while going
down, spiraling down in the world of l,
he actually was going to the right,
though he'd said that he was going to
the left and he was going to the left
because it was upside down.
Now he's right side up.
And so the directions of the
human world are going to be, uh,
to be regained.
So I turned to the right.
He will never use this image again
and set my mind on the other pole.
And I so far stars never seen before.
But by the first people, Adam and eve,
the sky seemed to rejoice in the flames.
All we do,
regions was the north since Dour,
denied that side.
The northern hemispheres where we are,
Dante's in the southern hemisphere,
he is connecting with us,
telling us what we are
deprived of in by not knowing,
by having lost a paradise.
A couple of things that I will not since
then we'll go back to these images.
Um,
the,
the way he literally orients himself,
let the metaphor he uses
is that of, uh, here, uh,
is the oriental light.
Uh,
and the way he's always
orienting a reorienting himself.
How do you know where you are is now in,
in purgatory and also in paradise?
When thinking about about,
uh, uh, characters, uh,
here on earth and, and, and,
and recalling their lives,
it's always by looking at the east.
It's always by looking in the light of
the east. And from this point of view,
Dante really retreats that most incredible
metaphor that is available among the
mystics, medieval
mystics. And I'm thinking,
or thinkers I'm thinking of even bullied.
He was Casio doors.
I hope they're not just
names for you who think, who,
who believes that you can only
think that we in the West,
a western in Clyde can only
think by looking toward the east.
That the way in which we can be orienting
ourselves is by trying to capture
that,
the source of that light.
And I mean this in the most
metaphorical and as we shall see,
the widest sensors, uh, possible.
But that's all he's saying now.
But at the same time and the language,
it's incredibly hard,
has shifted between the first paragraph
and the second paragraph that which
seems to be the excitement for the light.
And now he's experiencing again,
it's Easter Sunday.
He and he understands that it's direction.
This is going to hit him
very, very strongly now. Uh,
but it's also an allergic.
That tonality is Lhi.
And the idea of what we have laws
that widowed region of the Northern
Hemisphere, uh, the sense of
the sense of general laws,
though it's a provisional privilege for
him to see all this. But this indicates,
it introduces that the,
the,
the extraordinary tension
poetic pantry in purgatory,
the dialectic between excitement for
the future and then log for the past
pilgrim is called in between and we shall
see the consequences between this is
zero, the level of, of, of
tonality I would call it,
but we shall see what this
really means in a, in a moment.
This Dante approaches now,
um,
I had drawn my grade race and
so on. Uh, this is lines, uh,
uh, 25 when I had withdrawn my gaze
from them turning to the stars,
turning a little toward the other pole
where the wind had already disappeared.
I saw beside me an old man alone,
worthy, but his looks of
so great reverence that no
son owes more to a father.
His beard was long and stretched
with white and his hair the same. Uh,
double trust falling on his breast,
et Cetera.
This is going to be the
encounter with Keto.
And I want to talk about Cato. Wow.
Let me just give you a real bit of, uh,
extra, uh, Don Teske information. I mean,
in a way this is, you probably do
not know that this representation,
we call it, uh, this, this, uh,
the script seal of the old
man with, uh, the, the,
uh,
with a beard or white street with whites.
But on two sides really is the,
the paradigm,
the model that,
um,
Michelangelo writes a Michelangelo
follows in his conception of Moses,
though Dante doesn't lose sight of the
fact that this is Kate or just a little
piece of how Michelangelo Red Michelangelo
read this particular particular
meeting.
So who is this Keto?
And Dante describes as an old man,
and we also know that
he's a Roman pagan fat.
He's in Raleigh, a pagan.
He's a man of laws.
The first thing that
he wonders and he says,
pattern of who are you that
have fled you? It's, these are,
these are just, uh, are,
are people who have tried to
literally escaped from prison,
the eternal prison against
the bright scream. He said,
who has guided you or who was your lantern
in coming forth from profound night
that holds the perpetual blackness,
that valet of hair or the loss
of their best? Very Roman.
This is the room and tradition of the
law, right? How the loss of their best,
in a way, this is a man, was a
stranger to the world of purgatory.
Strictly.
It certainly doesn't seem to understand
that there may have been some grace.
It may be Dante and his guide that here
out of some providential intervention,
which has not,
not to be explained by Lowe's or by
natural or by the laws of nature or by Ben
men. Men made laws at the loss of their
business, broken or has a new decree.
He wonders, been made in
heaven. Uh, that being damned,
you come to my clips,
my leader Virgil,
the two Romans talk. Now I'm for
myself. Then I answered him. I'm sorry.
Uh, the Nance with him or
myself. I came, not a lady,
be Trish recapitulation of women fair.
No one descended from heaven
for whose prayers a sucker.
This man with my companionship.
But since this is a wheel
to have it made more plain,
how intrusive stands with us. It
cannot be mine to deny. Denied.
This man never saw his last hour,
but by his folly was only a twit.
That little time was left to run.
I will send to him and have shown him
all the guilty race and our purpose
to show him those spirits that cleanse
themselves under the I charge how I have
let him would belong to tell the there
descends from above virtue,
which aids me in bringing him to see
there and to hear the made please lead to
be gracious to his coming.
He goes seeking liberty,
which is so c so dear as he
knows who gives his life for it.
And the reference is clearly to Katelyn
himself who historically historical
failure actually committed suicide,
uh,
in the civil war and refusing
to take sides between,
uh, Pompei and uh, uh, and,
and Caesar as it's told in the great epic.
By looking the Roman Spanish poet
who wrote the so called civil war,
uh, a tax that is, uh, uh,
very polemical between in between
or among other things, uh,
with,
with Virgil that notice it since
death for it was no bitter to the,
in Utica, in North Africa where
the did sleeve, the vesture,
the body and which, um, in which,
which is a great day,
we'll be so bright.
The terminally dates are not broken
for us, for this man lives in minus,
there's not buying me,
but I'm of the circle limbo.
Where are they chase the eyes of Marsha,
his wife,
who in her lopes still praise the holy
breasts that are hold her for thy known,
for her love, then do, are inclined to us,
allow us to go through the seven kingdoms.
I will report to her kindness if that
deigned to be spoken of there below.
And he responds, Marsha, so please
my eyes. While I was younger,
he said then that whatever
kindness she sought of me I did.
Now that she dwells
beyond the evil stream,
she not move me more by the law, which
was made when I came forth from thence.
But if a lady, et Cetera, et
Cetera, um, it, this is an amazing,
uh,
from insubstantial terms and amazing
beginning in the poem because Dante Meets
Cato, who redefines. We are being
told there that he's an old man,
a pagan and the suicide there traits that
virtual singles out bleakly referring
to his adventures and that
clearly contradict the,
to purgatory.
Purgatory is a Christian
canticle this is Easter Sunday.
Why have it inaugurated by the presence
of a pagan who knew nothing of the,
of, of the incarnation? Why
have it? It's the, it's the,
it's the Rome of every new life.
Why started with the suicide someone
who we saw what Dante thought to the
suicide when in a, in a complicated
way, throughout, in fair,
there were a number of suicides
inhabiting various aspects of various,
uh,
regions of hell,
but especially among the Er with the
violent against nature and inferno 13.
And so an old man as
suicide and the Pagan.
Why does he do a figure
that he drove out of the,
the world of up of Lucas?
Um,
what we are told about him.
This,
it's usually whenever you have
representation so that beyond,
you always have a young man,
for instance [inaudible] or
is this is a kind of day,
the Latin term meaning a young,
uh, in the lien for instance,
it's always a young man or a young
woman welcoming to indicate the,
the renewed life. No, the novelty,
the freshness of our life. Uh,
you certainly don't have an old man and
you certainly do not have a suicide.
Now the question,
the suicide is probably the easiest to,
to determine cause Keto suicide.
It's a suicide for freedom.
And let me say a couple of things
about freedom because it's, um,
I call purgatory really the,
um,
the domain of freedom.
It's really the place of freedom that
he begins here explaining as it were,
political but also moral state. It's
a political because it's, it's, it's,
it's a refusal of the disarray and
chaos brought in by the war between pump
brought in by the war
between Pompey and Caesar.
At the time of the civil war.
But it is also a moral state because Cato
decides to put an end to his life in a
sort of sacrificial move as
if to draw attention to the,
that the, the, the way in
which the state had been, uh,
killed,
had been destroyed by the
rivalry between this two,
uh, these two great figures
who have not opposed,
but they'll have a rivalry about power.
That freedom is the fundamental problem.
It's a woman issue at me.
Just say non paid wants
us to think of it at, at,
at the very beginning of Purgatorio
in pagan intellectual terms, freedom,
uh,
the whole,
the whole precatory ends up with a pilgrim
regaining and being crowned as he'll
say with the attainment of free will.
So the whole poem really moves
this idea of from uh, uh,
Keto search for freedom, personal freedom,
and the pilgrim attainment of freewill.
Now there is an obvious relationship to
begin with between freedom on the one
hand and, and, uh, I would
say the future on the other,
right.
Uh,
the poem begins with the future and now
we are going to decide what are they,
what is the virtue of the future?
You cannot conceive of freedom unless
you have an idea of the future.
You cannot con you understand that the
connection between the two of you cannot
conceive of a novelty unless
you have an idea of the future.
And unless you have an idea of freedom,
the notion of originality
is actually even poetic.
Originality is impossible unless it's
tied to a certain idea of freedom.
It treats you poses the more so that
the attainment of freedom really means a
poetic originality ideal of the future.
The notion that things can be
different if I am a slave to the past,
if I'm a slave to a political order,
if I am a slave to my own vices,
internal as internalized as that quest
can be, then I really have no freedom.
Keto embodies one who refuses living
if living means living in a state of
tyranny to,
uh,
civil war violence and therefore
to the possibility of a moral life.
Okay, so that's easy to
determine. That's easy to explain.
I even think that the notion
of the old man can be expanded.
Dante wants to draw
attention first of all,
that somehow this search
for the future, he's, it's,
it's not,
not an alternative to the past.
It grows out of the past so that we,
we,
he's rejecting the idea that there may
be some sharp distinction between the two
and that the seeds of the future I don't
really contain in the past few years,
such as an old man,
a Cato.
The third problem is the
question of his being a pagan.
And this brings me back to that, which
is the project. Dante's project in the,
in progress toward the
project is that there is,
he must make a careful distinction,
which center Graston could not make in
the city of God. Damn. We'll make it.
That's his, that's Dante's, uh,
target polemic or target are Gustin
really distinguishes between the earthly
city and the heavily city and the
heavily city may live on earth,
but it's really a pilgrim
church going on told, uh,
told the beatitude and
the encounter with God.
The earthly city is corrupt
and in many ways, uh,
not assimilable to the, the world
of a, of the redemption. This is,
this is may if you are at another stint
eons and you have very supple view of a,
and may strike you as crude, but I don't
think that it really, it really, uh,
violates the essence of that dual idea
between the earthly city and the heavenly
city.
Dante is literally talking
against the Augustinian dualism.
There is in nature that is within
the pagan secular historical world.
There are seeds that can become crucial
for the making of the political,
for the making of a new moral life
that will be really consonant with not
dissonant,
with in a chord with the redemption and
the Christian redemption that he will be
actually seeking.
Keep this very much in mind,
a sign of this incredible tension time,
the meaning of freedom,
the value of the pagan world.
The insistence on the secular as as a
capable of producing some kind of a seed
for the future emerges really in
the second paragraph, wouldn't.
Finally a virtual tool bend, uh, to the,
the harshness to temper the
harshness of Keto says, look,
let us go through bills.
I know your wife very Italian.
I know your wife and I'm going to go
very back. This is to say, you know, uh,
I know who you are, so do me a favor
because I'll be doing that a favor.
Let me go and Marsha,
let Marsha.
I would go there and they'll tell
her what a great man you are.
What a good man you are.
What he's doing.
He's appealing to Kato's affective
memory and it is an appeal.
It's a solicitation that Cato refuses.
She can do nothing for me.
He refuses to be determined by the past.
You see the ambiguity's
they're running through.
Dante understands that
you have to go some,
the poet in the figuration understands
that you cannot really have a sense of
the future without being
rooted in the past.
And then here you have Cato who
can only make sharp distinctions.
She can do nothing about me.
I could tell you that this is a very,
the appeal to Marsha,
they appear to Marcia's memory for,
for Cato can become also
a cook is full of ironies.
And I,
I,
I would only tell you or I will
take us to too far a field.
I can tell you that in effect
in the history of Cato,
Marsha had left,
Kato had asked Taito to divorce her
because she wanted to marry somebody else
and that the death of the other,
the other husband,
Marsha asks Cato to
take a bag and she will.
And Dante is the accounts don't recounts
this whole story in the banquet and
views it as a sign of the
extraordinary generosity of this man.
So the th th th th there
is all of that law in the,
in the background of this reference
to Cato, but from our point of view,
then it is a question of the power of the
power of memory and the limits and the
limits of memory. And
then finally, um, uh, the,
he will go home saying, giving
some Mar Keto, we'll go on, uh,
giving us some, some mum, uh,
rules that he has to follow
in the process of cleansing.
You go and wash yourself
from the stain of in. I,
he will tell him and gird your
loins. They will be there. Uh,
he would mention a go to the desert of
shore, uh, therefore, uh, go and, uh,
uh,
this is the last pattern of the dawn is
the dawn song was overcoming the morning
breeze,
which Fred before it.
So that I described far off
the trembling of the sea.
We made our way over the lonely plane,
like one returns to the road.
He is lost until he finds it seems to
himself to go in vain when you were a part
where the do resist the sun. And being
in shade is little dispersed. My master,
Jen's relate both hands out,
spread on the grass.
I therefore aware of his purpose reached
toward him. My tear stains cheat.
That's the ritual of purification,
uh, which he had appealed.
We must undergo. And on them.
He hoarded, restore the collar,
which have I did an in me,
we came down on the Deseret shore that
never saw men sale its waters after had
experience of return. Whom are
you supposed to over here? Here.
What is the reference tool?
Andy Buddy.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
He makes it very clear.
The Cato and your listeners out of the
two pagans that he said difference,
he intrudes.
He in Sydney,
Wade's a distinction big within
the body of pagan culture.
You listen to on the one hand and his
own transgressive search for knowledge in
the belief that it really, there is
no knowledge without some suppression,
which is, which is considerable and
and worth would be worth considering.
And on the other hand, uh, the, the,
the experience of Keto himself.
Now here we are here with that different
at different pagan there he girded me
as the other head bitten.
That's a phrase that comes straight
out of infinite 26 or marvel for as the
lonely plant he chose such did spring up
again immediately in the place of where
he had parked it.
So Dan has to gird himself that way.
Jordany man would, whenever they
undertake a journey in antiquity, it all,
whether this,
the biblical journeyman or the Romans,
the gird that they fought this Gerbil
around themselves, uh, they, they,
the gird their loins. It's, it's, it's,
it's a moment of gone payment
of, of self, right. And that,
and that's the ritual he
has to, to undergo. Uh,
from my point of view though,
the emphasis falls on the power of the
natural world to the store itself because
immediately, and it's an emblem of the
resurrection here now, but it's still,
we're still in the natural world. That is
no, no element of grace nature. The, the,
the plant in an inversion of what
had happened in, in federal 13. Uh,
the plan is, uh, is, arises
again this born again,
and then we'd come to Ken
to, to, uh, the, the, the,
the situation changes somewhat. But, uh,
let me just begin another point of,
uh,
it starts with another
search for orientation.
And I mean that in a, it's
an easy pawn, the east,
the Orient and orientation
for the pilgrim.
And now it becomes clearly Jerusalem and
you will see the reason why it's going
to be Jerusalem in a moment.
Well,
one reason why they didn't just say it
immediately because has nothing to do
with the,
this has to do more with a,
let's say the myth about then with the
text is that hell and purgatory is at the
antipodes of Jerusalem, uh,
against the feet of Jerusalem.
Jerusalem was known as the, the, the, the
navel of the earth. And now we are in,
it's in purgatory, uh, edits
antipodes it's always starts already.
The son had reached the horizon who's
meridian circle covers Jerusalem.
So Tillerson will become the point of
reference with its highest Poland and
night circling opposite.
It was issuing from the Ganges with the
scales which fall from her hand when she
exceeds the day,
etc. I was white,
the rosy Chico Federal Aurora with her
increasing age where turning orange,
we still beside the sea,
those that ponder on the road,
who go in heart and embody linger and
extraordinary image of this location of
being both being body and mind and the
wear of a break between the two who have
expectations and hopes of moving ahead.
And yet they're kept in place
by the heaviness of the body.
And low is on the approach of morning.
Mars glows or ruddy,
uh,
through the thick vapor.
Slow in the west of the ocean floor
swore appeared to me. May I see it again,
a light coming so swiftly over the seat
that no flight could make it match it.
Speed. Uh, and here he
sees a boat, a fast boat,
um,
bringing,
carrying the souls of Penitence who,
uh,
reaching the banks of purgatory.
Uh,
they're very opposite to what we saw with
children's boat in how the boat of you
remember of, of the sinful, uh, souls. Uh,
and then an angel of gardens.
And then as the divine bird came,
told us more and more,
he appeared brighter so that my eyes
could not bear lines 38 a cast them down.
Uh, and he came on the shore with a vessel
source with the enlite that the water
took in nothing of it on the poops
too heavily steersman such as the
blessedness,
assuming that written upon him and more
than a thousand spirits set within.
And they sing a song he Nexi to Israel,
the Egypt toe. So on, according
to the vulgate one 13,
it's the song we're in,
which the Jews are remembering
their exodus from the bondage,
the slavery in Egypt to the,
um, to Jerusalem. That's
it. That's really the story.
This book of Exodus in Exito Israel,
Egypt,
you understand retrospectively
that reference to Jerusalem
that gives a kind of
unity to the whole Canto.
It's a song.
It's a song that are,
uh,
a number of things about this.
The only,
the only text that Dante
sites textually sites,
he made references to the Bible all time.
But the only text of the Bible that done
through really sites literally in pigs
from textual,
it is always the book of Psalms,
probably an acknowledgement
that it's poetry. Uh, and,
and that he responds to that poetry.
But I spatially he does so and our only,
because it's the probably the text
where for the first time we have,
we have a representation of subjectivity
in western Western consciousness.
It's the story of someone who is looking
inward and finding out the diseases of,
of, of self, the appetites
that passion's et Cetera.
That may be what reasons in say
is engaged in that kind of a,
he himself appealed and was
engaged as sort of quest.
But there is another reason I believe
because the psalms are basically lyrical
recapitulations of the story of exodus.
So that Dante's saying that exodus is
the figure that the divine comedy is the
lyrical representation of the story.
The Biblical story of exodus that he too,
that is human history is
engaged in that search.
A search from slavery to liberty.
So,
let me just pursue this a little
bit from another point of view.
In Canto one of Pro Victoria, we saw
that the presentation of Roman political,
moral liberty.
Now we have an idea that the whole of
history is really engaged in this exodus,
a journey toward liberty,
two types of liberties,
a Roman one and the Jewish one
which Dante wants to connect.
It is as if he understands
that there are two traditions,
both of which are based
on a quest for liberty,
that there is a sense of in both
of them though in different ways,
a sense of beginning that
he must try to harmonize.
He must try to explore and probe in depth.
What do they mean and what are they
about in one a kind of legal idea,
uh,
moral political idea of liberty,
Cato that comes to a point of self
destruction. And the other one,
the question of spiritual exos,
by the way,
a second thing I can say about this
reference to, uh, the, this psalm one 13,
is that Dante uses it as the basis
for explaining his use of allegory.
You remember that I spoke about the
allegory of poets and allegory of
theologians and that the difference was
the historical basis of the narrative,
sort of exos for dentist
historically. Uh, true. It's an event.
So this gives a kind of biblical Figaro
Aura to Dante's representation or they
go record a presentation at least.
Uh,
and the third thing has to say is
that the story of exodus in many ways
embodies,
um,
crystallizes the real intellectual issues
of what is this photo of exos about
horse. They leaving behind the
house of bondage or as they call it,
the house of bondage.
Uhh,
they taking along the
gold of the Egyptians,
which really means the secular knowledge.
A secular knowledge is also part of what
we must carry with us in the journey
toward freedom. That's that's, but it
also means that they stay in the desert.
The Jews stayed in the desert for 40 days.
They feel that they're abandoned by
Moses who has caught up to receive the
tables of the law.
And what are their abandoned,
they engage in idolatry.
This is the story of exodus story of the
people caught between I dollar tree and
revelation and promises
and prophetic promises,
prophecy and idolatry.
And the ideology shows
itself as a statement or as
an experience of nostalgia.
That's what the,
the making of the golden calf is
a statement and way of, you know,
desperate is,
they may be because they are now leader
less and they will be for a while.
Then they engage in a,
uh,
an act of a desire,
a longing for at least the safety or
what they perceive as the safety of their
dwelling in Egypt. Mindless of
the fact that the were in bondage.
This is if safety,
the safety of living where
preferable to them even in,
if that is a safety, uh, uh, provided,
procured and in the shadow of a,
of tyranny of bondage.
So you see this as a,
these are the concerns that Dante we'll
have as it comes into a program. Toilet.
The whole Purgatorio is literally a
journey of what we were looking back and
forth between the future and the
past and the future and the past,
her rivaling with each other for the
control of the mind of the pilgrim.
Let's see how this is going to be, uh,
developed. Uh, and I hope I have time to,
um, uh, go give you time for, for,
for questions because I, I'm, I'm really,
I realize I'm saying a lot of
things in there. A lot of things.
I am not even saying
the poem,
The candle shifts from this
grand historical concerns,
this reflections on how the pagan
world experiences beginnings and new
departures only with an ideology
of freedom and this idea,
biblical idea of,
of a new beginning,
which is really a break with
slavery, a break and, uh,
the, uh, the retrieval
of the idea of, of, uh,
of freedom in a
general one historical way.
Now it shifts the narrative
shifts and the, it's,
it's whole internalize the
pilgrim moves within himself.
And the first statement is that
he does not know where he is.
And that's an emphasis.
This was a way of alluding to this
exhibit exhibit predicament he has.
He literally has,
he does not know where to go.
He already had indicated that his state
of mind was as that that have one who
with the mind keeps going toward some
place but with a body his kept behind you
remember that line which,
which clearly dramatizes the split with
a kind of inner self dislocation for the
pilgrim and now he just is no meeting
this penitent so souls who are as lost as
he is,
uh,
about the place and they all
ask him for directions which,
which, which were they are singing
in exit with there in that desert,
the desert to be in the desert.
Where is the desert?
This is where one is the desert.
If you don't know which way to go,
the desert is the unmapped space
between Egypt typological speaking and
Jerusalem. It's some space
in between. I have no roots.
You have no paths, there are no
carvings and markers left for you.
And so they ask him,
you can you are lions sips
and foreign if you know,
show us the way to go up the
mountain and virtual answered.
You think perhaps we are acquainted
with this praises but we are strangers.
That's what it means to be an exile
and that's what it means to write this
poetry of exile. That Dante,
we'll right this a pull,
that Oreo is the place of the desert.
There's a spirituality even of the
desert and certainly the statement of the
exit condition.
We really don't belong here.
We're always displaced and going somewhere
else and the end up at the basis of
the Dantes or religious longing
there is the sense of displacement.
There is a sense of where we are somehow
out of that our hearts are out of where
they should be. We came but now we're a
little while before you buy another road,
which was so rough and hard that another
client would seem to us as a pastime.
The souls who had perceived from my
breeding that was still in life turn Pale
with wonder and this to a messenger who
bears and olive branch that people crowd
to hear the news and no one,
he's a crush.
So every one of his fortunate souls fixed
his eyes on my face as if forgetting
to go and make themselves fair.
Now he then becomes the object of
temptation for the penitent souls.
They should be going somewhere.
They should be going up the mountain
and yet they stop where they are.
So another, another way of
thinking about forgetfulness and,
and the sense of, uh, of, of uh,
of a name of a place to, to reach.
Let's see how this is developed. I saw
one of them come forward. There's so many,
so much affection to embrace me that
it moved me to do the same or empathy
shades except in sandbars
three times a clasp.
My hands behind them and there's often
brought them back to my breasts. Wonder,
I think it was painted in my looks at
which the shade smiled in Lubeck and I
follow him, pressed forward
gently. He obeyed miss then.
Then I knew who it was and begged me
that he would stay a little and talk with
me.
This little detail of the embrace,
the field embrace is one of the three
failed in braces and way of acknowledging
for the pilgrim. And NASA had
knowledge that the really the soles,
you have no substance reality
that we can grasp. Okay.
Um, this is the first and there will be
two more that I will talk about as we
proceed. He answered even as
I love the my mortal flesh.
So do I love the, uh, fried,
therefore a stay? But thou,
why are thou on this journey?
Micah Sela Dante meets a friend of his
youth and musician and musician who
probably had even said to use it,
not his own poetry, men from
Sienna, clearly his died.
So it's, it's uh, uh,
to relieve the hardship of the
journey as this is a parent.
An exist are more a moment of indulgence,
a way of a meeting with a friend,
a little pastoral interlude if you wish,
uh,
to break up the,
the hardness of the desert and the
implications of, of that metaphor.
The world of, not the quest,
but now the pause, the pause of,
of refraction,
the paws of relief,
the aesthetic relief that this can give
him my cassela to return at a time.
But why are you, uh, or take this road?
But from the how has so much time being
taken and he said, no wrongest than me.
Uh, et cetera. He explains
how he got here and die.
If a new law does not take from the
memory or practice of the songs of love,
which used to quiet,
oh my longings.
They said that this clearly
is a reflection on the
power of aesthetics and on
the limits of aesthetics made.
Please do refresh my soul
with them for awhile,
which is so spent coming
here with my body.
And so Casella starts singing a song,
which is a poem that Dante himself
wrote and now he sets it in music as he
probably may have done in this life.
Love that this course is to me,
my mind, he began then. So sweetly,
the sweetness sounds within me stale
and his sweetness is to be understood as
the attribute of musical harmony.
I know the sweetness and I indicated
this when talking about the, the is,
it's always the language job
of, of the Palette and, and, uh,
the savoring a certain savoring
that goes on with the gluttons here.
It's really a musical attributes.
This, the quality of the sound. Uh,
and, uh, my master denying these
people who were with him seemed to sec,
it's contentious.
If nothing else touch the mind of any,
we're all wrapped into attentive
to his notes. When low Cato,
the venerable old man crying.
What is this laggard spirits?
What negligence,
what the glaze,
this haste to the mountain to strip
you of the slough that allows God to
manifest to you. Uh, okay.
So here is an aesthetic, the,
the uh, an anesthetic enclosure. Uh,
the port listens to his own song with a
little touch of narcissistic amputation
there. His cassela is playing
up to him, reassuring him,
giving him a sense,
this is you and I know who you are.
And they're all wrapped and they forget
about the ascent. And then of course,
Keto comes the ethical voice, the voice
of the law. So you may have a kind of,
you may even want to write about this
scene as a sort of conflict between
aesthetics and ethics.
How are they working against each other?
But one thing is clear here that Dante
is forgetful of the real lesson that he
had learned in the encounter with Keto.
It just happened that Keto himself,
therefore he intervenes.
And His anger is,
it's the anger of the teachers.
But I just explained to you
what the problems are. Cato,
Virgil had approached Cato hope and had
hoped that Keto could be swayed by the
memory of the past in Cato had
rejected the power of that memory.
He of the, the affection or even
in the pleasure of that memory.
Dante comes in Cantu too,
and he's involved in,
let's call it even an idolatrous moment,
the moment where he just witnesses some
things that he has been making, uh,
that he has built, he has
composed, is taken in by it,
but essentially it that has the power
to distract him from his own ascent.
He has forgotten the reasons
why he is here in purgatory.
And so the whole program story begins
with the s the explicit statement about
the importance of new beginnings,
new departures,
the recognition that everything new and
the future can only come out of some
sense of the past.
And then the discovery that
the past can interfere,
can intrude.
And therefore the steady process of
a continuous quest that continuous
rethinking a opens up in front of
the pilgrim and in front of us. Um,
and the, the interesting thing and the,
and he had, I stopped, Keto uses one word.
What kind of negligence is this?
And you know what the word means?
Negligence. We're all negligent. But what
are we, when we are negligence, what does,
what does the word called pain?
Since they were talking about beginnings
with pollution, but at the model j,
which is the language of beginnings,
negligence means not
to choose what Keto is.
Reproaching Dante and his guide and all
the other souls is reproaching the power
of poetry to produce this
atmosphere of non choice.
Ah,
and obliquely that's then what his ethics
is that we always engaged in an act of
choice.
He speaks from the perspective of freedom,
which literature or the [inaudible]
has the power to tame and somehow for a
moment at least here neutralize.
So you see the extraordinary degree of
self reflection and self reflection as it
from all points of view.
And let me stop and see if
there are questions and the
hope to be able to answer
some of this. Uh, um, elements in
the introduction of prudent pouring.
Yes.
He talks about leaving
behind her so clueless.
And they struck me about the
arc of his intellect leaving
the barcode was with, it's
called in English. Yes.
Is um,
is that also a reference to
past poetry tradition besides,
I mean I read it as sort of, um, he's
looking behind me right now. Yes. It is.
It also reference to how he's
leaving behind and excelling past,
uh,
past epic tradition.
The question is the metaphor, the
beginning of Purgatorio when the, the,
the poet,
so he's leaving behind a such a cruel sea.
Uh,
the crew seems to be in this,
actually we can agree easily add
reference to two in fair. No.
But then the question is, can
it be also reference to pass
epic, uh, uh, traditions?
Uh,
it could be,
but you would have to be a little bit
more specific about what you mean.
The all this, say for
instance, or the Aeneid, uh,
journeys by see Dan pays the divine
comedy is constantly imbricated with his
other, um, poems. Uh,
and in fact,
uh,
the great poem that he recalls a
pass epic traditional is Luken. Uh,
and he chooses Luca because Luca is,
so I'm coming back to your car,
your, your question and tried to,
tried to welcome it and say that
indeed the it, it's possible,
but I have to explain why
I think it's possible.
The Lukens Pharsalia is a unique text
epic and the epic solution because it
deliberately places itself as a historical
or historical work that polemic of
[inaudible] toward Virgil
is that Virgil sure.
He had been talking with was talking
about the foundation of Rome.
And for the Roman, there's nothing more
historical than that. As you'll know,
the Romans had the peace holds a practical
people that will count. We'll, we'll,
we'll, we'll calculate history
from the foundation of the city.
They never a scheme about the garden of
Eden or be the host that's rioting about,
uh, uh, unknown events
in the past or whatever.
Uh, the Roman starts with the
foundation of the city, live it there.
So, uh, Virgil writes about the origin
of Rome in front of the point of view.
He a historical author, but he,
he mixes his historical accounts.
It's so much mythmaking that
Luken rejects the form of poetry.
And he writes in epic about
the civil war. Luken, uh,
writes about Caesar and Pompey,
which clearly is a boy of other braiding
and other more pressing civil war that
between Anthony and Augustus
and, um, and, and, and, and, and,
and alluding to the one
between Sula and Mario's,
the whole sequels, civil wars that
had punctuated and given it's,
uh, uh, it's, it's, it's the
quality and the, the, the, the,
the distinctiveness of,
of Roman Roman history.
So,
uh,
in a way I would say that Dante is
rejecting a certain type of a epic poetry,
uh, that deals with, uh,
some kind of generalized,
a metaphorical account though.
For instance, he's, he's,
he's going to be Jason. He's going to be
a knee as I'll give to keep her in mind.
It would be a turn to,
uh,
at least in Canton one a
turn to the historical world.
And we've making poor gatory
part of history because
that's really the secret or
purgatory. Purgatory began by saying it's
part of human geography, you remember,
but not all of human history. Dante
wants to make it part of human history.
We really can go back to the garden
of Eden if not directly through some
reconstruction and shadowy,
um,
re figuration something that looks like
there will be of the garden of Eden or
something like that.
Not really utopia about something can
approach the older of the garden of Eden.
I must have confused you with this,
this answer and if so good. Thank you.
Well of course not, but I think that I
was going five different directions that,
and I apologize if I did.
Yes,
journey
poetry has the power you want to,
you can work your way to clarity
through the beauty of the poetry.
And then you were just
talking about though,
how aesthetics can get in the way and
how you can have a neutralizing effect.
And could you just talk a little
bit more about the tension there?
Like what do you think to the common
rule which you should be able to let you
act towards the action and
then they'll still neutral?
Yes.
Great question.
The question is that I begin
by talking today about, uh,
the journey of poetry and really ended
with the idea of the danger of poetry
that are that aesthetics of confrontation
that are the pure that the poet Dante
has with a poetry of his own youth.
Ah,
so what gives about this tension?
Since I'm talking about a tension
between two modes of poetry,
I claim on the one hand that poetry
is for Dante, the way of knowing.
And then he has seems to get in
the way a scandal. It's a scandal.
It really stomach makes
us, makes him stumble. Uh,
so what is this a,
the connection between these two,
these two forms? Yeah, that is,
that is a really great question.
I think that Dante understands
that. Uh, first of all,
let me just give him a great deal
of credit. By the time Dante writes,
poetry was still by and large a little
game that the province are poets were
playing in the codes of pro Vance and
northern Italy where little games about
secret love stories,
little games about hunting,
et Cetera,
or the great poems of
the so called goal yards.
The gluttonous one said the belly
worship, Dante comes along and says, no,
this vernacular poetry can really become
the medium for knowing everything up.
Everything that we can humanly
can about ourselves, about God,
and about all the things that we can,
we believe in and the things
that we would like to believe in,
all the hopes and defeats that we have.
So that's a great idea of what it means.
And so it's from his point of view down
to engage his poetry within the circle
of knowledge of what I call the
encyclopedic commpass of knowledge.
So he involves all the sciences,
but at the same time that you
asked me to think about that day,
electric one is not
conceivable without the other.
In order to really know,
the first thing that poacher has to do
is show that it knows itself usually the
way, the reason my poetry is it's
treated as a, as a lonely art.
You know that the,
because this meretricious it doesn't
sa it gives itself to everybody.
Uh,
I'm saying all of this builds the scene
of canto to really recall a great scene.
We haven't got time to go into that
in recourse, in other grades in.
And I think that Dante's really rethinking
the famous opening scene of fuse,
the consolation of philosophy,
which I don't know if you have read,
but I have mentioned it, but you will,
you look like someone who would go to the
library now and pick up the beer. It's,
it's really, it's really a
book. It's a no, I'm serious.
It's really a book where
the philosopher is sick
in bed.
He is, he does not know his
disease and other to find comfort,
he picks up a book of poetry. The musers
go to him. What's up a book of poetry,
which probably is what most people
will do with the got the flu.
It's time to read good poetry,
right?
And then all of a sudden
lady philosophy your peers.
Yeah.
And banishes this musers get the hands,
you hollered,
he calls them of the theater because
you don't give any real remedy.
You just only provide provisional solace.
So what [inaudible] is doing is,
so the whole [inaudible] philosophy
is really better than than poetry.
Hey, way of recasting the
old platonic oral as, as we
know from even the republic,
right between the debate between poetry
and and and, and, and the, and philosophy.
What Dante's doing this, no, no.
Poetry may have this dangerous
temptations, impossibilities.
But that's what makes it part of
its own self knowledge. I want to,
I can not guarantee or promise that
poetry will lead you to knowledge unless I
show that the medium
that I use knows itself.
It knows its whole own temptations.
It's known,
it knows its home meretricious
possibilities. You see what I'm saying?
It always a comp one.
It says,
would you want me to highlight the reasons
of that day elected that tension and
that the only answer I can give is
that one flanks, the other constantly.
So the voice of Cato and the voice
of Casella there at the same time,
they belong necessarily
belong together in, uh, the,
the unfolding and the articulation
of Dante's old Nah voice. This is,
you know, you cannot expect to have one a
while then. If this is really dangerous,
can I have something else?
No, no. It's not either or.
It's both end the either or the ethical
or the aesthetic and the ethical,
uh, as if they were to a
post forms just will not.
Okay.
Other questions?
I wish you had another hour here so that
I could really talk about some of these
details, uh, in the, in the, in
the beginning of the poem. Well,
since I hear none, no other questions.
Thank you. See your next start.